hey guys I'm Ryan Wright and I'm Alex
Robinson
Alex Robinson from the real mr. Robinson
is here and today we're gonna talk about
terminator genisys covering some
spoilers I saw the real mr. Robinson
he's a fan of the channel saw a couple
of his reviews literally this guy's were
intellectual than I am I didn't even say
intellectual properly all right so let's
just hopin it some direct spoilers
alright I kind of mapped out things I
wanted to talk about in order Doctor Who
is Skynet Doctor Who is sky now we're
gonna start off with that apparently
yeah how did you feel about that I
personally have not seen much of Doctor
Who so well the promise that much is my
review you see Matt Smith in some of
those cheesiest [ __ ] promo ads before
the first trailer even came and threw
every trailer we don't see him at all
and he's in this movie for like about
three minutes he he's the one that grabs
John Connor as Kyle Reese is sent back
to 1984 and apparently all the soldiers
surrounding John Connor don't do jack
shadow notice yes and then he turns John
Connor into the T 3000 and he said
stupid low hologram all over Cyberdyne
saying you're not gonna kill me you're
not gonna kill me I mean that was pretty
funny when no one notices it I mean Kyle
Reese is about to [ __ ] time-travel
yeah you know he can never take his eyes
off John Connor because he really wants
put his dick in his mouth that proves
that the first thing he's by for the
first 10 minutes it's it's a pretty
homoerotic relationship and this guy's
not even realizing that's his son so
John Connor was taking Skynet played by
what's his name again
Matt Smith Matt Smith I'm pretty sure he
signed some contract for like three
sequels or some [ __ ] I'm pretty sure all
these guys did cuz this is this is
supposed to be like an official reboot
for the series until James Cameron gets
his rights back well whether succeeds or
not he's getting him back my issue with
that scene that really bothered me was
there you said it in your review I
couldn't tell the times if this was a
reboot or a sequel that was ignoring t3
and for one thing that really threw me
off cuz I remember watching terminator 1
there's a scene that goes to a flashback
of Kyle Reese Terminator attacks
underground he has Sarah Connors photo
it
burns yeah it just disintegrates into
ash in this movie when John Connor is
like talking to Connor races Congress is
undressing he sees massara ha when he
sees the photo fall I'm like that photo
wasn't supposed to be around at this
particular point at this yeah it's
supposed to be gone that was a big fault
on their part and the stars really not
really good or it's more bad in the
writing because you just have writers
that just didn't really do their
homework outside the fact that how could
when they go to 2017 Sarah Connor Kai
Risa how is it
John Connor whether he's a terminator or
not how is he still how does he exist if
they didn't if Sarah and Kyle didn't
[ __ ] in 1984 yeah I know that that was
my I had that complaint on the
Terminator - on his trailer when I was
bringing up that point because this
movie especially this movie makes it
very clear that John Connor was born
before the Judgment Day Kyle Reese was
born after Judgment Day yeah and then
they have a whole scene where Kyle Reese
and meets John Connor and he's clearly a
kid at the time it makes no sense that
was my biggest problem with this scene
when Kyle Reese finds out I was like
that's kind of a funny moment but why is
Kyle Reese not being like hey this
doesn't make any logical sense how could
I be your father didn't even bother to
try to explain it through some weird
time-traveling thing they just dropped
the whole subject most mmm that's my
Spock
that's your Spock yeah sure Spock some
of your impressions sound very similar
to other impressions you do I'm sure
they are there were things I liked about
it with the old MA jizz and the
replicated shots yeah I know you felt
differently about that though I did my
problem with basically remaking the
first movie shot-for-shot was you
could've easily use stock footage for
some of them like I know for the punts
you can't bring pill bill paxton back in
that'd be cool it would have been a 60
year old 1980s kicks family just
reminded me of the remake of psycho it's
like you're not you're really doing
these scenes again but not adding
anything really new for some of them but
then there is I will change when the old
Arnie comes up and beats the [ __ ] out of
the young Arnie you see that's why I
like that though was because at first
it's like Oh
just replicating first one and then they
add twist to it like okay Isis wakes up
he in front of the bum seals his pants
and then he would then a t-1000 attacks
him I like that they were [ __ ] with
what we already knew and then pulling
you know twisting awesome I guess
another problem I have is that the
actors who have to deliver that original
dialogue aren't very good like the bomb
in this one is just like hey man did you
see a really bright light and and then
the original it's like hey man did you
see a really bright light like it's
cheesy but it's a little more believable
then yeah we this is the problem with
like it's a little weird when you're
like let's take young Harney
specifically young Arnie well let's
recast other people yeah and so they
recast these characters but the prom is
is that they were looking for imitations
not sincere poor trails or sincere
performances yeah so that's why they
came off like fake and kind of making
you wish like I was I wish I was just
watching the original one right now and
I feel like could have shot around the
gangsters too like especially the Bill
Paxton one you know like they could just
use the original footage and then cut to
a different shot when the old Arnie
shows up or what would have been better
is if Arnie
oh the old Schwarzenegger was hiding
behind the truck that the new Arnie
appears at like just before he gets a
chance to rise up yeah it's just like
come in snap the neck what did you think
about the t1000 coming back one thing I
had that bothered me about it grabbed
the bat was there was no real
explanation as to why they sent a t-1000
back just to wait for calories that
wasn't too fond of it because the t1000
is like in the movie for about 10 no
maybe less than five minutes and then
just goes away
yeah my bigger problem with something
involving the t1000 and this is actually
something you've turned me around on I
was like you know I couldn't do like
Arnold turning or getting an upgrade to
the t1000 at the end but then you like
talked about it and like yeah that's
[ __ ] stupid yeah well in my opinion I
don't really like you because what's
made Arnold so cool cuz Arnold starts
off Terminator 1 he's a villain he's
terrifying it's a t800 yeah then in part
two they topped that t800 with the t1
yeah then the Turman matrix it's even
more about and then Sam Worthington is
even more of all you got this new
terminator and so what makes term Arnold
Schwarzenegger Terminator cool is that
he's a classic he stays the same he's
always a t800 but figures out a way to
win yeah that's what makes Arnold cool
cuz he's like a thinking machine when
you make him a t-1000 it's like oh come
on we made him [ __ ] awesome was that
he was you know vintage yeah was the
t1000 it's supposed to be the same one
right no I mean because this guy's
clearly Asian I don't think he's
supposed to be the same one but I think
again it's just like hey remember this
awesome character from Terminator 2
remember that he's dressed like a cop
remember
yeah that shot in the eye and repairs
himself don't you remember all that cool
[ __ ] it's like yes and I'd rather be
watching the original movie that had
that cool [ __ ] this is the spoiler that
was a real [ __ ] spoiler that's in the
movie yes in the trailer yeah you
mentioned it in your spoiler free review
but I felt like it was my duty to not be
the trailer or the main poster and just
say you know what if you've never seen
the trailer then I'm just not gonna
mention it no that was that's cool you I
don't care about people enough the John
Connor twist when you find out John
Connor is The Terminator
I like is the Terminator villain now I
like the concept of that more than I
like the execution of what they did with
it the concept of it was interesting to
me because every movie John Connor is
the savior and in this one they're like
no he's the Antichrist at this point you
know right something about the way it
was executed I felt like this is the
moment when John Connor is a brand new
Terminator and there was already so much
[ __ ] going on that by the time it got to
that it was like well I'm already
keeping up with everything else what you
know like this isn't gonna this is just
another piece of a bunch of different
terminators now it's not the strong
emotional impact need to be and my
biggest problem too was the way [ __ ]
Sarah Connor this is just like all right
we gotta kill him it's that simple
they're just guys shoot him yeah we
gotta shoot my we can't kill my son that
I don't really know that much about it
I've committed my whole life to making
this work my problem with that with the
twist is he's not really that mother
it's like the TX he's not really that
much of
advancement from the other models like
he's not nowhere near threatening as the
t1000 like I think the t1000 is the
pinnacle of threatening terminators yeah
I know he's actually and you know the
problem I have it's like it's a bit
different that John Connors taking this
role but the promise we'd never had
adult John Connor has never been
portrayed well like Nick Stahl in T 3
was pretty much a bum and had Shia
LeBouf mannerisms
Christian Bale was I thought the best
but that's not saying much at all cuz he
just channeled Clint Eastwood and all
the focus is more on Marcus Wright than
John Connor and salvation and then here
you got another chance to do it and you
make John Connor that's been built up
for the for the first movie and so many
other lore and you make him the villain
Wow alright you gotta just flip me on
that yeah alright because at first I was
like cool twist but now you're okay oh
you got a good point there actually yeah
because we never really got the right
opportunity to see this Savior this
leader do his job yeah the most we saw
it was him looking through binoculars
and t2 and just I mean did you like like
the first 10 to 15 minutes of Genesis
because I liked seeing John Connor doing
some leadership stuff I actually kind of
did I mean the only thing I didn't like
about the opening outside of Jai
Courtney was John Connors motivational
speech was sort of laughable to me I
didn't really it just came across as
cheesy but I did like the future scenes
and I did like old Arnie in the fact
that they touch on the fact that hey the
tissue on the t800 is actually aged yes
really something that's the one only
part in the movie that's actually clever
yeah we I mean we both covered it in our
reviews that are not spoilers do try our
opinions on that you should check it out
but the other day we liked it and it
[ __ ] works and I really appreciate it
that they took the fact that Arnold
Schwarzenegger is definitely aged since
Terminator 3 and they use it in their
advantage rather than having to work
against it so so for anyone who feels
like oh manda I like the real mr.
Robinson hates every bit of that movie I
don't it's still [ __ ] in my opinion but
there are good elements to it you talked
about this dude in your review I didn't
mention him JK Simmons in
this movie first off I love JK Simmons I
think that a fantastic actor he shows up
in this film and he's a totally
different type of character than we're
used to seeing him as he's only like the
man in charge and knows what he's doing
well
this guy was kind of looked at as like a
loony so no one really believed him and
they thought he was like that crazy
detective you set this character up like
he's been following this case for 30
years he wants answers he gets nothing
he gets shot he gets nothing there's no
answers and the three protagonists just
abandoned him yeah I'm really wondering
if this movie's gonna succeed like if
it's gonna make money
no yeah because the Salvation flopped
and Arnie's not really been on a hot
streak after leaving his post as the
Governator what are you talking about
escape plan was a major hit so was the
last stand so it was Maggie I'm pretty
sure they didn't make money and then the
last thing we should cover Kyle Reese
unnecessarily giving a message to young
Kyle Reese even though Skynet has
officially been terminated that's the
part that made me laugh at the end it's
like yeah Judgment Day is done we
destroyed Skynet the heroes track down a
young Kyle Reese and old Kyle Reese goes
up to young calories how many times
gonna say Kyle Reese and says remember
Genisys is Skynet it's like you [ __ ]
destroyed Skynet why not giving that
message no reason to traumatize yourself
my main issue with that moment is
actually that entire last scene I didn't
like the way was executed at all it was
cheesy felt like it was from a different
movie that kid when Sarah Connor first
shows up she's like hey what are you
doing here I got a friend wants to say
something you okay what's the message
all right I'll remember yeah and then
they make out and when I just don't buy
their chemistry when Sarah Connor
encounters the Younger calories in the
hospital yeah it like doesn't come
across as like you can like she's trying
to help this kid it comes across as a
little creepy yeah and it just
establishes more of how does John Connor
really exist because Sarah Connor
is an adult with a shotgun and this is a
10 year old boy running around alright
guys well that's it for today we wanted
to just give some spoiler opinions here
if you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects you could
check out the real mr. Robinson he has a
bunch of great reviews on there
seriously check it out there's some
Let's Plays - and you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram Twitter me on vine he
doesn't have a vine follow us on our
social networks because if we get enough
followers he could get product placement
and I could get more product placement
yeah
money is amazing for things such as
puzzles puzzles are great yeah you know
the greatest puzzle is figuring out the
mystery to a woman's vagina of how to
eat it out that's a mystery that I've
been trying to solve for 24 years
something tells me that when Kyle Reese
goes down on Sarah Connor she's gonna be
really hairy and it's gonna turn him off
but then again people from the future
are probably really hairy - yeah you
know you got to think about these things
people put enough attention to detail
into the person's views but I think
pubes are gonna be a big part of the
future when the term rays get sent back
through time do they have pubes do they
not have peers we need to know these
things writers know I'm pretty sure that
when they sent our knee and the t1000
back they were shaved they look shaping
the TX even though we didn't get really
get to see her snatch but yeah there's a
lot good thing that would we could have
done yeah in what can you do that's what
the Internet's for
there's I'm sure there's Terminator porn
out there there is come on if you live